la certeza del vencedor una nicaragua
sin campaña política en las avenidas del
país no hay ninguna alusión a las
elecciones generales del próximo 7 de
noviembre la previsión de los resultados
es tal que ni el oficialista frente
sandinista hace publicidad sus
seguidores deben comprarse un souvenir
si desean honrar a su partido desde
antes del 19 land v buscando y noray y
ahora que tuve la oportunidad de venir
aquí y la puedo comprar la compre
enrique núñez consiguió una bandera del
partido sandinista aunque extraña las
épocas cuando el presidente daniel
ortega se tomaba el tiempo para
conseguir votos yo me acuerdo cuando yo
estaba chiquito él llegó una vez a la
intendencia allá del mercado oriental y
yo lo vi persona de persona cara a cara
no como ahora porque cuesta hacer cárcel
ahí lo tuve yo a la par las elecciones
han causado controversia porque siete
candidatos de oposición están
encarcelados y varios partidos fueron
suspendidos por el órgano electoral para
este politólogo ortega ir a unas
elecciones sin competencia prácticamente
los candidatos
y que todo ha sido colaboracionistas
son gentes desconocidas prácticamente
para el público en general y si por
añadidura no tienen o no hacen
propaganda quién va a ir a votar por
ellos
aparte digamos de que mucha gente está
decidida a no votar porque prácticamente
el frente eliminó a los que
desgraciadamente le podían hacer
oposición ortega de 75 años aspira a su
cuarto mandato consecutivo como
presidente
su esposa rosario murillo también busca
reelegirse como vicepresidente del país
hasta ahora los lugares de venta de
camisetas y souvenirs políticos son los
espacios donde se siente un ambiente
electoral en nicaragua el presidente
daniel ortega no necesita invertir en
promoción
su triunfo es casi un hecho